yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby
welcome kiddos to the fighter and the
die yeah dude wait for you to change
that name I know dude well it's official
today C sucking Crowder off in Dallas
yeah I know so I sent out the bat signal
and you're the here I am dude here you
are dude looking good with the Philly
hat even though they lost yeah well I uh
I love this is in solidarity you know
I'm a sad they lost I was going for uh
Phillies cuz uh Bryce Harper is my son's
favorite human being my favorite
baseball player dude how good actually
yesterday I wish I'd have done it it's
in my car yesterday all yesterday I
played softball for like two and a half
hours and then we went and and hung out
and you know went watched football and I
kept taking my hat off and I had the
Philly fanatic headband underneath like
Bryce Harper wears I love it and every
chick was like I was like it's Bryce
Harper dude it looks cool and I also
love the Philly fanatic I love mascots
hell yeah so I thought it looked cool
under the Hat I thought Philly was going
to get it done and then you're watching
I know you're a big baseball fan you're
watching the World Series oh I don't
even think we should talk about it you
know last time I did I did Golden hour
and you know I'm still at a part in my
career where I'm like all right let's
just see the comments see if anyone's
talking [__] why do you look at comments
well I'm still I still you know I don't
know how I'm doing with your fans dude
people were so nice to me but so garbage
about the baseball talk they're like I
like Jeff D what's all this baseball
[__] some facts about think about L
Garett I thought they think it was
interesting I thought it was dope I
enjoyed it told everyone Tai cobs a
racist piece of [__] and everyone's like
what's with all the baseball this isn't
about baseball it's about kidnapping
homeless black kids yeah you had like a
little M that's interesting that's not
baseball and Babe Ruth you you'd tell
him where to pitch yeah Babe Ruth being
a black guy that no one talks about I
thought it was interesting but sorry
fans of uh well last one on baseball cuz
you're the best person only person I can
talk baseball with besides your son
besides my son but it's only Bryce
Harper if it's not Bry Harper he's not
into it but originally I was going for
Texas I like their I like Seager a lot
from you know used to play for Dodgers
so I love Seager or it's Adis I love
alas Garcia monster but so I like the
hitting the hitters on uh Texas but I
like the bullpen for Arizona so I find
myself rooting for Arizona this guy puts
the glove up to his air all the time why
does he do that because there's a
speaker in his hat and he's trying to
hear it cu the playoff's so loud what
they have little things in their hats
that so the catcher has a button here
that he picks the pitches and then it
says the pitch to him so he can actually
hear it it says oh so he's doing this
stepen Hawking in his hat going
curveball what happened to the days cuz
they don't want him reading slve they
don't want him reading the cuz they were
able to pick up the sign yeah yeah they
steal sign as this just takes care of
the signs stealing oh wow yeah but it is
kind of fascinating too cuzz like like
the fact that they're letting them do
that is weird weird yeah but people are
already trying to cheat with it there
was some college baseball team that took
the pitch com and just put them in their
batting helmets and then there was a guy
over there cuz it's not like major
league Major League Baseball is a higher
product so they were like using iPads to
steal what the signs were and then
telling the batter in the helmet fast
Ball's coming so they were already
trying to steal it and then but the
catcher was like yeah but it was so loud
I could [__] hear the pitches so they
caught him like immediately and and they
couldn't justify like oh no we put this
batting we put this speaker in the
batting helmet for batting practice we
forgot it was in there they're like the
frequency just got mixed up I guess dude
way cheating there's just no way people
always get caught are you doing dude I
love that where'd you get that hoodie I
bought it at some stupid shoe store by
my house man I wish I bought you ever
going to those of course you actually
you like I don't I don't go those
sneaker those sneaker stores they're the
worst I feel like when I walk in they
should go hey turn it around Bud yeah
yeah not you're too old you're too old
for here what's with the boots yeah not
for you you're not our demo my man yeah
doesn't it feel like that they got 700
pairs of shoes that are like shrink
wrapped and then and then they have like
sick ass like jackets and hoodies and
shirts nozes no if you could walk into a
Tik Tok that would be those stores ex I
hate those stores and I know people like
them but big [__] dumb uh teddy bear
made of plastic you can't play with or
hold and uh and it's like $7,000 cuz
some artist you've never heard of
[__] made it yeah then there's like
Pokemon cards and then I'll be like go
those those dunks are cool you got sizes
like all we have is a seven man all
right dude do you have any 13s at one
that's in plastic yeah only in plastic I
I hate those stores and those are cool
stores if you smoke weed all [__] day
and you want to date kid cuy like it's a
[__] dumb store the whole culture of
that is trash yeah I don't dig I that's
aggressive take but it's just so stupid
I don't like those stores they have one
machine where you can put in like a
dollar and maybe you can push a key
through a key sized hole that'll win you
a pair of Yeezys or something dude my
buddy Brett had that business in Canada
and was making bank to some guy on
YouTube they're all they're all shady
yeah they're all shady Bill bich you're
stealing stuff out I also saw a YouTube
video that if there's a way to like
figure it out there's some sort of
something and this kid figured it out
and then they he's been get he keeps
getting kicked out of the stores really
cuz he'll win and they go hey like
Blackjack we didn't mean to give away
that iPad yeah it's like card counting
like he knows the trick or whatever but
my boy Brett Forte had that in Canada a
bunch of malls and was making bank for a
while and then the gigs up I guess also
to be if anybody's listening go Jeff
sounds like a judgmental piece of [__] I
bet you feel that when you go into
[__] Target you know you go this
place sucks and I like Target so it's
like it's okay I'm just an old man I
think your store sucks and it's
overpriced there's a bunch of [__] I
wouldn't want that's all right yeah it's
fair Target's the only this girl keeps
shaking her head no I don't know what
the problem is I don't know what the
problem is is that where you find black
guys you can
date sorry I offended the the Youth of
the
Nation why they going to be black you
can of course black what are you talking
about black well cuz they're either
black guys or white guys that dress like
black guys and talk like black guys
that's what young people do now
everything's like yo what up dog I'm
like where you from Idaho oh you're from
Idaho you talk like that oh when they
say bro yeah I don't know what's going
on dude drives me nuts my son said I was
like go to your room yeah dude don't say
bro I went to apartment last night my
buddy bow was like we have to go to this
thing I said I was going to go can you
please drive me cuz I wasn't drinking I
was like yeah I got you dude so we drive
to this apartment and it's like three
chicks Stone out of their minds like a
tattoo on her like stomach she's only
her nipples are covered and she's like
got a blunt and she's like painting a
pumpkin not carving it just painting it
and she's like she's like she thinks
she's like Picasso over there she she's
[__] think was it good though no was
terrible and also she's not talking to
anybody she's just like in her own like
blunt world like painting a pumpkin and
then there's three girls that look like
they've been completely medicated and
they're just like on their iPhones I
walked into this place I go yeah we got
to go immediately yeah we're out of what
is this what the this is the party SC
this is what hot young chicks look like
now yeah dude just like go like Hot
Topic chicks Hot Topic cheerleaders it
was terrible that's what they look like
yeah well I like at least the rap videos
make it seem like they're all doing
stuff and dancing and having a good time
yeah maybe only in that culture in the
urban cultur they said they were just
lazy they were like lazy on a couch with
like sweat bottoms and like no top and
just like a blond G
like Jasmine I'm like G [__] get me
out of here
these chicks need to stop smoking weed
and get a [__] life are you doing
anything for Halloween um so I'm try I
feel like you do you're like a Halloween
part I did Hollywood horror nights twice
already at Universal at Universal it's
[__] sick dude what's the theme this
year um I'm not sure been every year
except for this year oh really every
year it's kind of the same stuff they
have a Chucky ride over here well last
last time it was uh the weekend I think
this year's Exorcist was the new one cuz
that new ex movie came out it was good
was good yeah the movie was good and the
amze was I love Halloween [__] me too
favorite holiday you know what the
interesting thing about Hollywood horor
nights no fat people oh my God there's
no fat people because I did I took it on
my on my on my watch you have a counter
it was like 7 and half miles of walking
oh to get down to the haunted house well
because there's all the es upper lot the
lower lot there's it was 7 and half
miles and you got to run my feet are
hurting and I'm I'm in good shape dude I
started going wait there's no fat people
I started looking around I was like yeah
there's no fat people it's not a fat
person thing yes it's not a fat person
you got to move they should put that on
the ticket hey if you're fat good luck I
hope you didn't buy the front of the
line pass just pick one maze sit in line
all day hope you don't have the fast
pass yeah yeah you get just get a meal
and go to one maze go to one cuz I'm
telling you dude it was so much walking
it's crowded too though yeah it's very
crowded packed it's warm if you don't
have the fast pass you might get two
haunted houses in no like one or two
yeah maybe two you're right maybe two
then that's the worst in 6 hours but if
you buy the fast pass you can go to
everything which is like I've tell all
my friends which is kind of what sucks
is that like my friends can't afford you
know
$550 ticket and the food socks that they
give you you're going to spend money
when you get there of course and so like
I basically I used to go all the time
when I worked at NBC I would just buy
everyone the tickets or whatever but
this year I just like bought one for one
other person took like a girl yeah you
just need one person with you yeah so
would seem like a serial killer well we
can't bring all like my some I've got
very rich friends and I have some
friends that are like dude I can't
afford
$550 to go like to a a night of
Halloween with my friend Jeff and then
I'm also not going to spend $600 so my
buddy Aaron can go with me no get drunk
and not appreciate the goddamn haunted
night but but you who do you take your
kids cuz it's pretty scary it's too
scary for them no me and my wife would
go and then we would usually invite her
brother and his girlfriend or we'd go
with another one of my friend's uh
parents one of my son's friends parents
dude Halloween stuff's the greatest my
favorite holiday Queen Mary used to do a
good one but this year it's called like
sha toober that's when I was at I wanted
to go it's like Shack fast oo
rebounds o free throw watch out hack a
shack can he make a free throw you
that's a scary o assists assist like
what is that [__] it used to be super
scary that boat is actually haunted in
real life allegedly super haunted so
it's like really it was fun to be there
and they had all these Ghouls and Goblin
and then this year they just got check I
don't understand it made me not want to
go yeah I was going to be down for it
cuz I went to uh around here there's a
uh was it night of the Jacks which is at
the King Ranch in calabas heard this oh
bro you got to go is it still going not
it's still going it's still going you'll
love it they have a whole like whole
thing set up with lights but where it's
at one of my favorite shows is Ghost
adventur shout out to Zack baggin okay
and I'm watching right and they're like
we're in Calabasas California like where
the hell they doing in Calabasas and
then they go to that where this jackon
nights at it's called King Ranch bro
it's like top 10 most haunted places in
America I'm there froling with my
goddamn kids uh when you see it because
they murdered a ton it used to be Indian
land they murdered a ton of Indians I'm
like all right that's standard in
America yeah yeah if you if you know
anything about history it's funny they
go like the plot of these movies like
turns out our house was built on a
native burial ground guess what
everything in America is built on a
native burial ground that means
everything's haunted everything that
means everything this podcast studio is
probably over some native bones 100%
like if you know much about how how it
worked yeah 100% but that so it says
it's the haunted place and I was like
right Native Americans like standard
that doesn't scare me but then I get so
it's the King Ranch and there's the like
buildings there like looks like a church
I guess like a satanic cult took over
for like 30 years like murdered people
and buried them in the basement oh my
God I take my kids here man I had a
[__] corn but was it scary no so the
thing's not scary it's like pumpkins
like scen
carved friendly yeah kid- friendly but
and then adult there well it's you'll
love it looks cute yeah it's it's dope
the only one I've never done is not
scary farm it's fantastic it's good yeah
okay not Farm during the day is garbage
so when last time you went though uh in
2010 with my girlfriend at the time dude
I said so I went probably 2010 2012
ghetto yeah the Riff raft of theme par
oh yeah just gang members I was more
afraid of the gang members that were
hanging out hanging out there than the
actual and you know how like Universal
has like Marvel and The Simpsons and
Disney OB has Mickey Mouse and cars Bush
G like nottsbury has Charlie Brown yeah
Snoopy's walking around and go what the
[__] I don't remember Snoopy I'm 40
years old D I took I took my son he's
like what what the hell is that I'm like
I get that giant white dog yeah and they
sell Jam boys and Berry Jam I here's
your son what the [__] a
Woodstock yeah so we went like whatever
10 years ago we went probably 3 months
ago it's only a 30-minute drive from
here they invested like $15 million in
it cuz somebody died on the on on the
roller coaster okay some kid with mental
issues jumped in to get his hat got his
head taken off oh my God so like we got
to put money in this thing now it's so
legit it's good are is there a lot of
people there no okay it's it might be
the best especially for kids the best
one part of my judgment of nber farm is
I went with my girlfriend at the time we
were like just always trying to just
find anything to do and since we were
like new to California we just did every
tourist thing every whatever so we show
up and it's just us it's like a Tuesday
afternoon I was like oh God it looks
like we rented the whole place you don't
need the VIP pass there oh my God we got
on one of the uh rides and it took us
all around and then the like jaded
teenager that's working was like like
you want to go again cuz there was like
no one in line or anything and we're
like ah [__] it run it back and we just
did it like twice even on the roller
coaster like me and my son you just keep
going cuz there's not that many people
there I took him to San Diego went to
SeaWorld again you don't need the VIP
pass for SeaWorld there's nobody there
those will be closed in five years yeah
but it's funny cuz you're yeah you're
dealing with the teenagers and I'm like
you guys still have killer Wales I
thought that since black mirr came out
or black mask came out whatever it's
black we don't know man black fish
employes heavy on the black yeah but
when I when we went there I was like hey
man I thought since uh black fish came
out you guys can have the whales like
the killer whales he's like a man that
thing's all hyped dude don't he's like
you can still have the ones but we just
can't have new ones and then I we look
at him we have like dinner or lunch and
he's like swimming around his Fin's like
this oh exactly I was like man he looks
sick he's like dude again that's all
marketing yeah dude he's he's happy as
hell to these Dolphins love it here and
the Dolphins going with like foam coming
in
no look at how happiest yeah it was sad
it was when you see like the way he's
ramming his uh his nose into the glass
that's happiness you know what you told
me that's how they showed Joy you all
that blood they love that they love that
man they live for it dude they live for
it noce Finn was like this the entire
time he's swimming around sad as [__]
like chasing fish that there's frozen
fish are tossing to him and I go man
that's not normal like in the wild you
don't see a lot of that he's like oh
it's the um when he doesn't get enough
Sun the you can tell dealt with this
question he's like when doesn't get
enough Sun kind goes down it'll get hot
out you'll see it pop back up I'm like I
guess dude solar power this sad also I
love the idea they like no they're
actually um sad in the wild that's what
they don't tell you in the wild they're
very depressed they like it here no you
know what he did he goes this thing's
probably better than here man these
things are murderers out there in the
ocean man you seen these I was like yeah
whatever dude talking about four [__]
trainers last
year have you ever watched that story on
those no I've seen everything on it one
year I gave like $30,000 to dolphins CU
I watched the
cove and I was just like I was like [__]
people dude we got to help these
dolphins and then I just realized what
am I doing dude what am I doing your
money goes nowhere it's so stupid yeah
so stupid Hayden pented area whatever
name just like counting my money going
we got 30 grand more from a [__] Jeff
TV guy but yeah that was the movie that
broke my heart cuz dolphins are cool man
they're like dogs water dogs water water
pups um yeah but like yeah that's why I
said SeaWorld's only going to be open
for like 10 more years at most 5 years
10 years they're trying to go away from
Netflix has came out it's like forget it
dude every documentary is just about how
garbage we are uh we eat too much
Seafood we eat too much meat we're not
eating enough meat there's a milk crisis
too much water running out of water
every dock just makes humans feel
terrible but and then then then they
hype up the seal killer ones they're
like they're like Jeffrey dmer just
struggled from mental illness I think we
should show this guy a little compassion
you know that Hitler was just
misunderstood yeah you know if they just
passed Hitler's art project you wouldn't
have this problem I hate that cliche
I've heard 75 comedians go you know
Hitler was if he just would have got
into art school it's like I clearly you
know nothing about history yeah he he
was yeah he did the art thing then he
went to war and it broke his brain yeah
no matter what that's what happened it
wasn't like he could have went back to
his goddamn painting class no he had to
go to war even if they gave him the
scholarship yeah no matter what um what
I was I going to say about the uh animal
thing I forget the uh you watch oh all
the Netflix thing so so I watched a
documentary uh what's that gay football
player Tim TBO is Tim TBO you thinking
of Aaron Hernandez homosexual no he's
not dude he's married you're think of
Aon Hernandez no but here's the thing
they do that whole doc about um about
Tim TBO okay or not Tim about Florida
it's got Urban Meyer Tim they left out
all the darkness here's what I don't
Brothers how are you not going to put
Aaron Hernandez that's what I'm saying
and they're like well because you know
what he did right and he's dead yeah
dude you make documentaries about
murderers all the time Netflix they have
one on there already you glorify every
serial killer and and there's a whole do
about Aaron hernandz but then you're
going to make one about Florida and not
mention Aaron Hernandez once Aaron
Hernandez and also the pouny and then
also there was other guys on that team
who did horri mentioned Percy Harvin who
but like he never did anything bad Percy
never did anything but he wasn't even in
the dock they mentioned him like maybe
once nothing that doc sucked yeah it was
but it was all about Urban Meyer yeah I
know but I mean like like get six people
for that documentary you spent millions
of dollars at Netflix and you got like
six people because one lineman they
didn't want to talk about the darkness
there was a murder that happened like on
campus right around campus and urban
Meer covered up like there's so much
Darkness there why don't why not make
that
dock it's going to be on BET after
dark I won't see
it I got Netflix dude I got Netflix dude
well here's what I understand about all
those things is like so like uh um
winning time which I thought was a
fantastic show about the Lakers like
Jerry West uh Kem Abdul Jabar all these
guys they were really pissed off they
were like this is ridiculous this it's
like dude Jerry you've famously been an
[__] for for your whole career and
now you're going to you're mad that they
made you look like a prickly [__]
it's like that's just that's how things
it'd be like making a a documentary
about me or a show about me and then I'm
like why' they show me drinking all the
time it's like you drink dude you you
can't not have your bad they also made
you look good you have good quality my
only thing with the drry West stuff is I
don't have any interaction with him so
oh he's a terrible guy but that's
according to you like who it's according
to 100% of the people that have ever met
Jerry West so maybe he is I ran into him
I was at with my family at lunch with
another family and I saw him and I
recognized CU his watch was ridiculous
and I'm like God damn it the tall old
man I'm like oh that's Jerry West yeah
and then my son was like Dad who is that
I'm like he's like a Laker great he's
the EM the NBA yeah he's the logo his
nickname was the logo and I go but he's
not a nice guy yeah and then after I
said I'm like I don't know that well no
it is a so here's the thing with Jerry
West now he did in the face yeah he
kicked my kid yeah so that's how you
know no she believed it I really did for
a quick hell no you know what the hell I
do he probably would open with that part
of the story not defending his
honor uh no so here's the thing Jer was
incredible basketball player uh he's
great to his friends and family which
that's easy to do everyone's nice to
their friends well I'll ask my
dad well so like Jerry was nice with his
friends and family he's an incredible
basketball player he's a great
businessman he was a good coach there's
many good qualities he is one of these
kind of guys who's nobody in nobody out
of the circle so if you're not in the
circle he's just rude and has no reason
to be nice to you and and so yeah you
also that's your reputation his
reputation is terrible he he like unless
you're in the circle of trust has
publicly said terrible things about jeie
bus the owner of the Lakers who has only
been sweet to him has only taken care of
him has only been she out of the circle
though she's out of the she she was
never in his Circle what did she do to
get out of the circle uh she was never
in the circle in my I'm she be sharing
we need to talk to Jerry cuz what I'm
like hey what's what's it got to take to
get Jenny in the circle it's now here's
the thing jeie bus like if you just
Google jeie bus and Jerry West he has
publicly said terrible things about her
yeah why would she need to defend him or
defend her honor like she owns the
Lakers and he's a guy who works for the
Clippers and thinks that he's just he's
said a lot of bad things and so like
when you say bad things publicly that's
how life works and then he gets mad that
they made it into go can you believe
they made me look like a little prickly
yeah dude you're prickly I can't believe
also why are you defending Jerry West
over there what did he give you free
tickets or
something I'm not saying anything yeah
you're a hot chick he's probably real
nice to you no he's live in a different
world than us yeah yeah girls like this
they're like uh oh oh do you know the
game he's so nice he's like yeah to you
he gets you a car service and gives you
bottle service and you go why does
everyone say
them well he treats me like dog [__] and
he treats you really good and you can't
see outside of your world like but I
it's like being Hitler's wife like he's
nice to me he's nice to our dog you I
don't know if you see the gas chamber is
about a mile from our house
babe but he's nice to me you're so
stupid yeah we're a good guy with you
obsessed with Halloween like I do watch
a bunch of scary stuff like I will only
watch scary stuff until Halloween oh my
first girlfriend in Los Angeles my first
girlfriend in Los Angeles did this thing
cuz I wasn't always into like Paranormal
stuff and I wasn't always into like like
YouTube you can YouTube Sir Spooks or
nukes top five or any of these things
that I watch all the time and it's like
real videos of people on Ouija boards or
real videos of like a shadow person I
mean allegedly but they claim that
they're real videos so she I was never
into any of that [__] and she was like
for Halloween can we watch one scary
movie a night we were like living
together and I was like yes we watched
31 scary movies which was such a fun
thing and sometimes we'd miss it so we'd
watch two on Friday or whatever um now I
do it all the time I look for scary
stuff every single day it's so fun it's
pract all I watch bad nightmares
whatever worth it oh obsessed with it
got my black belt and serial killers
paranormal on three your favorite scary
movie 1 2 3 barbarian o sinister's good
have you seen Barbarian
no it's so don't bring it up I don't
want him to see a word but but what's it
on let me oh you can let me just see the
cover I bought it on iTunes and I've
probably watched it 20 times it's on HBO
Max but don't watch a trailer or
anything is it a is it gory or is it
like actually scary no Gore cuz I don't
like Gore like I don't like like Saul
what part
without saying without giving anything
away it's not really but I need a
thriller I mean there's blood but every
horror film has blood um is it the one
with Justin long that's yeah okay so
yeah incred I don't remember any Gore
either it's like [__] the movie is
like what also is good about it without
spoiling anything is it's like three
different movies yeah at one point you
go oh I see where this is going and I
like it and then it turns and you go
holy [__] and then you go oh I like this
too and then then the you think but now
it's this it's like that movie uh where
they had that Asian family living
downstairs the Korean family
yeah the one the one Oscar yeah what was
it called what a [__] great film but
like halfway through the movie you think
you know what you're watching and then
it turns into this whole leather you go
whoa so that's how Barbarian is but been
for like an hour h house on the hill
like I like that black uh was it black
mass or midnight mass is good well the
haunted house on the hill is that that
that was the series right yeah so good
with the kid from ET is like a dad but
he still looks like the kid from me yes
um no so that show was good and I liked
it but it was one scare per episode I
was like come
onar what about midnight club same
producer same director midnight club's
good I haven't seen lot of scares with
that drags on a little bit stranger
things was good the first season and
then it like season three dude I haven't
seen season three cuz I I hated season
two so much oh you like season 3 is good
season 2 they just like they started
doing like corny like Mall montages and
like so I like it cuz it's like tribute
to like the late 80s 90s that's why I
originally like it all Kid cast like
Goonies are stand by me I like wona ryer
I like the synthesiz [__] it's a period
piece I like Monsters I like conspiracy
all this I like I was all in and then
the second season like the hot kid is
now working at a hot dog stand and he
can't get girls you're like that was the
hot kid and he's like remember they made
that they just keep adding girls so woke
time they they made that to the woke
time so the handsome like kids like the
loser now he get like bullied I'm like
when he just beat him up though right
and they add like a redheaded girl who's
like not to be trifled with no I like
she's my favorite oh you know how girls
are we're just as strong as boys I like
her though Billy um but whatever what's
this that house so it's called House on
Haunted Hill right yeah it was good show
the so it was a remake I guess so yeah
that no that the one on Netflix J not
the one from
1999 hold on I'm not watching that
[__] House on Haunted Hill yeah
still the same it a remake but uh it was
very it's from a book yeah wait The
Haunting of Hill House there you go The
Haunting of Hill House that's the name
yeah good damn it came out why they not
have the dad as like one of the first
photos he's like the main character and
look he's not even in the top six
build according to google there he is
Henry Thomas he's in a midnight club too
he looks just like that little boy I
can't see anything but that little kid
from ET uh wait go to back to the first
chick the first chick uh Kate seagull
never mind I'm getting Carly guino mixed
up with someone else Katie seagull is so
pretty She's a Lesbian though lesbian
celebr Crush besides ianka Trump uh
Katie seagull and Carla
Gino guino guino yeah she did the first
time I did The Tonight Show she was the
other guest she pretty in person yeah
she's really pretty she's nice she's got
that weird theater thing though actors
are so weird I've met like 10 actors
that are cool what that's your celebrity
crush uh she's like 60 um I don't know I
don't really have one no none Meg Meg
the stallion that counts
I don't know man sex I don't know celebr
crushes no we have different celebrity
crushes yeah yours like Taylor Swift no
it
isn't uh trying to think of my celebrity
crush St would be a fun time that was
the most it used to be like Amanda Pete
do you remember her from I don't
remember her she hasn't aged great but
like she used to be uh like when she was
oh oh from Saving Silverman yeah back in
the day she was oh no uh saving uh it
was she was hot um interesting that's a
deep dive got actually I can go deeper
than that my one of my favorite when I
was a young man cuz I had three sisters
they were always watching all this girl
[__] um Parker posie remember her no man
do '90s Parker Parker pory Ty me Peter
Peter
Porker I don't know who you're talking
about Parker posie she was in all these
like uh really funny comedy and she was
very funny yeah she was very very funny
and like cute and see that one right
there with she's got the soda pop she's
like she's like boy our Stu she's kind
of a white trash chick in the in the in
the movie not in real life but she was
like why can't I see the soda pop where
sometimes oh she's got like a soda right
there she works at Dairy Queen down down
down the one where L down where she's
working she yeah cuz she's like an
improv comedian so she would always be
like yeah I like working here cuz we get
free Coke and uh sometimes just on my
break I'll have a Coke like she's just
like a white TR but she was very funny
that was your crush huh yeah she was
funny and I was like are you also into
Jim
Carrey no she's cute what are you
talking about she was in scream yeah
yeah yeah what was she the she played
the the girl that is it Courtney Cox is
that no that was Courtney Cox who played
Courtney Cox Cox played Courtney Cox but
she played the movie version of oh damn
deep
cut see that oh yeah I see it okay she's
pretty yeah she was pretty if you watch
her like back then I mean these photos
are dated obviously look at those bangs
yeah rough look at Courtney's bangs W
talking I'm trying to think of my
current keep dive though I know I'm just
going through all my so was like Parker
posie and then I liked uh I when when I
was a you know why I say make this St
may maybe a because you know your
influence when you're a kid I had the I
think my brother had the album cover
Mercedes this thing from uh from No
Limit Records yeah where her she's on a
car and her ass is out yeah maybe that's
why I'm into black I've never been an
ass guy in my life really '90s kid I
like a beautiful face and some tits but
I can do without the tits too as long as
she's pretty wow yeah if she's pretty
and like not
fat I don't my sisters are big jacked
off of that thing man boy Bo hey is that
Michael oh God you got bro you got to
clip that up I used to jack off to that
that's so when I was a kid
BR yeah that that Shadows Mercedes bro
shadow makes it look like her vagina's
crooked
do you see the Shadow on it it makes it
look like her vagina goes to the right
yeah that's the least of my worries my
problem in my problem my problem is
their face looks like [__] Michael
strayan oh yeah it's tough dude like
that I didn't you know what I didn't see
the face as a kid notorious p u SS y
dude look at that face is it weird I was
into that man notorious that and micro
machine I didn't even know she'd been
around that long I've never even I don't
I've never heard her music I know but
that wait oh so is this not Meg the
stallion no I thought that's what you
were doing I thought no no this I was
like mer I was like 10 when did that
album come out I don't when was I
jacking it to this can I see what she
looks like
now oh dude let's see what she looks
like now dude she looks like Morgan
Freeman
now she looks like Morgan Freeman I I
just clicked on the first link I don't
know if this is her oh she still
crushing it no she's
not we're all
silent uh she looks better now yeah dude
let's keep it going there we go there
she's with masterp still doing the
thing this is what the apartment looked
like the last night I was at right here
just a bunch of chicks chilling on the
couch like talking like doing looking in
their own phones [__] there's a whole
party going on and they're just looking
in their dumb phones smoking blunts just
on Tik Tok yeah just looking at
themselves there's all these strangers
they just want to look at themselves
yeah life will come out F yeah time is a
[__] you only have 75 Summers
man
75 only have 75 Summers if you're good
you know that is that's depressing
that's sad right it's super depressing
the chin showed me this motivational
video of Eddie Murphy going you only
have 75 aums 75 sumers makes it puts it
in perspective I find I've heard that
kind of thing a lot and the like you
know like you'll probably only see your
parents if you see your parents two
times a year probably only see your
parents this when he started doing the
math on that I was like hey man I got to
turn this [__] off exactly cuz it didn't
motivate me it made me
sad sister like hey you know I love you
right [__] you know I'm only going to
see you 64 more times listen this is I'm
by 10 more times yeah I barely see
you I'm not going to visit you more I
just want to let you know I love don't
get crazy I going out there more but we
only see each other 12 times according
to these calculations you know I love
him it's probably five times J's video
was good though play for Jeff Jin it's
not my video Jin was like I got to show
you this I was like oh God I love
motivation stuff if you saw my what I
listen to on a daily basis you guys
would be like this guy's [__]
cornball I like motivational stuff but
this one in particular I don't know why
cuz we know we're going to live to like
maybe if we're lucky what it says 75 but
you're Asian you have aund something
okay something maybe I don't know but
mean as a bigger white guy I have four
Summers now that's not true take
advantage I do talk about big this guys
all the time I say it like I like L I've
said it on this podcast man I'll just
stare at Brandon so like we at the
Lakers game I just was like I looking at
his head and then he looked over and I
just looked back just like I'm always
I'm always I tell everyone like you been
around Brandon dud he's like he's huge
and by the way you're so tall I'm a big
guy but brenon just gigantic big guy big
hands big [__] head yeah so this is a
clip hopefully for war for war man if
this was 200 years ago I put all my
money on him I go hey
goey we want one of those we want one of
those give us one of those bring that
model over here let's buy him yeah we
want safy we going buy him over here man
I don't want my wife raped bring in the
Warrior yeah he would be our give him
whatever he asks
for okay here's a clip real quick 75
it's from holy man how much time you get
if you're lucky 75 I've seen this win 75
spring times 75 Summers and 75 autums
when you look at it like that there not
a lot of time is don't waste them get
your head out of the Rat Race and forget
about the superficial to preoccupy Your
Existence and get back to what's
important now right now this very second
and I'm not saying drop everything and
let the world come to a grinding halt
I'm saying that you could become a
Seeker you could be loving more you
could be taking some chances you can be
living more you be spending more time
with your family you can be getting in
touch with the part of you that lives
instead of fears the part of you that
loves instead of hates man I should have
played this for those loser girls in
that apartment last night hey [__]
they need to hear here man I'm living my
life dude you guys keep smoking those
Vapes you got 30 Summers hey wake up you
drug induced [__] losers hey that
rainbow Vape you're sipping on you got
20 robot you keep sucking off all day
give it up robot go to Equinox get a
[__] life dud that's a that was
beautiful I love that good I like that a
lot when you put in perspective like 75
Summers Winters I'm like [__] well and
also that's 75 what that's he's talking
to babies there
cuz I think that I've only got like you
know a little bit left I that's yeah cuz
I'm 40 I don't think I have 115 years
you know it's gets a little dicey I've
already used all my Summers before here
in holy
man seems unfair W no that's really
beautiful I like that kind of stuff they
added some music to it I mean the music
stuff it always adds to it I don't know
who made this I have about 30 quality
Summers left 30 that's crazy right 30
Summers man you're in fantastic shape
most people get old and they they can't
even enjoy the summer D I'm like a Great
Dane you great Dan's live like six years
yeah dude my buddy had a great dane and
they they had to feed it at the same
time every day or it get bloat and I was
like dude my dog eats Whatever Whenever
the [__] I'm around like there's no
schedule for my dog my dog goes yeah my
owner is a [__] jackass sometimes I
eat sometimes I don't sometimes he takes
me to the bar sometimes he forgets
just but like the other day fed me three
Skittles I just this is like cool story
I used to come back from baseball and I
would just like sit on my couch Li my
shirt off and like watch baseball and
then my dog I would eat a bunch of
grapes that from my fridge and then I
would like give him one and then i' eat
it he must ate a hundred grapes they're
so bad for dogs someone yeah every goes
you know that grapes will kill dogs I go
my dog eats like a 100 grapes a day and
they were like they're like that's
terrible like I had no idea also my
dog's fine he's just like a little
junkyard flourishing man look at his
skin dude eats rocks sometimes I don't
feed him rocks but he just
Jeff's like yeah I don't know what's
wrong with my dog I give him a 100
grapes and a bars of chocolate yeah he
loves chocolate dude when he has
chocolate he'll just lay there I mean
he's so happy no that's not never gave
him chocolate know what I was going to
say about uh Great Dan my bu had a great
day and and like like he said I go why
do you feed him on to like he would
leave like a restaurant to go home and
feed the dog at the exact time and he's
like cuz he gets bloated I what that he
goes his stomach will turn over and like
he'll die if he doesn't eat at the exact
same time all the time great Dan are
just a lot to take on like when I was
looking at dogs I looked in Great Danes
and you talked to like the Breeders like
you better be ready man like same thing
you eat the same time you can't run them
a lot cuz they're you have to replace
their hips like this is a terrible
investment they have about six good
years I'm like I don't want my kids
around this thing it's going to die he
starts dying as soon as he walks in the
house yeah what are they made for cuz no
dog all dogs were human invention what
was gr Dane made for they there's like a
royal lineage isn't there there's like a
whole royal St it is called great is
your nose pierced yeah okay you st was
the reflection no I thought she was like
a boogie
dripping like I thought that was like a
little like a great Dan just a little
ring looks good I just thought it was
snot eight fun facts about Great Danes
they lived three years they were bred to
protect Country Estates and hunt wild
boes so what happened to those great
danes that could run and kill a boar
pussified them Americans got a hold of
them and say for how long they could do
this but they they can't like you can't
take them on a lot of walks you can't
jog them a lot cuz they're hips oh yeah
there just a Russell Wilson has two of
them that makes sense yeah so I heard
great Dan's making terrible
football I knew it was coming dude
they're so bad although we beat the
Chiefs yesterday I know which made no
sense to me how' that happen Taylor
Swift Cur dude oh my God yeah and also
this is how famous she is is she the
most famous person in the world I'm
watching football and then all a sudden
they put a graphic like when Taylor
Swift is in the building the Chiefs are
I'm like what why is this like a
statistic oh it's no your fan base we
don't give a [__] it's really you can
show her once and then move on yeah I
don't yeah and I like when they cut to
celebrities in the crowd but like I
don't need a statistic of how well
they're playing when she's in the
stadium like you like this like when
Tyson Fury and Francis fought this
weekend it was 5 hours of filler cuz the
the pay-per-view started at 11: M the
fight they didn't to so watching for 5
hours every 3 4 minutes like Kanye West
is in the building Ronaldo how about
Ronaldo's here oh there's Conor McGregor
I'm like God these guys are searching
for [__] any filler they can get one
of my biggest West is like when someone
goes to a game and they're like every
time I come they win and I'm like how
time how many times you they been three
games ever you're like yeah I don't
think I don't think it's one of those
it's not a factor like it's just like a
fun thing people do but now Taylor Swift
really is at her house gone yeah they
even put on the screen when I'm in the
building we win the only real like
monetary thing Taylor Swift does when
she go the ticket prices are through the
roof yeah cuz you know then the kids
want to get in and that's bad I saw a
video I think it was on might been on
Instagram I think so where this guy he's
he's V video recording his girl and
she's like oh my God she's like it's
crazy Taylor Swift made Kelsey so famous
nobody knew who he was before Taylor
know love and he was like what he like
say what I hosted SNL
and in the [__] NFL for like the last
five years lady Also let's look at Kel
can we look at Travis Kel's last
girlfriend there's a a dramatic
difference between Taylor Swift and this
girl my how my how Fame really uh
changes your
type she's gorgeous this is Travis Kel's
last girlfriend and he's like you know
what I'd like a skinny
richer version he was like what's Jeff
Dy into no that is not my type Taylor
Swift is not my type he went from a
young Brendan chob to a current Jeff Dy
well and also he's gone uh may maybe
she's pretty actually pretty sexy yeah I
remember her being a little different my
memory was wrong no uh smok show I've
seen her in person too she must be
pissed I you think she cares I feel like
she got more famous from this no she
came out and was like bashing him and
saying Taylor be worried like he's a
narcissist he's going to cheat on you
like she bad yeah but that's common
[__] uh ex X talk gabber you know how
Loosely we use the term narcissist and
sociopath I don't think you've met one
if people don't they use these words
yeah nobody knows how words work anymore
yeah sincerely whether we just toss it
around sociopath I made so I I'll tell
you a quick short story I was uh
performing at a a comedy show or
whatever and this girl went on in front
of me she sucked at comedy right and uh
but she tried you know good work and uh
she sucked and what you do is when you
when you go on after a comedian you kind
of tease them a little you know yeah
everyone does yeah you say oh you know
whatever like you make a little joke or
whatever well her comedy was like uh
I'll give you an example like one of her
jokes was like I married my husband it's
not love like I he has good credit or
some bull easy you know easy thing
basically like this guy's some loser and
she goes really what I just is a nose
job you know I've got a cocaine problem
all this different stuff she's just
saying all stuff and then she's like any
guys in here do yoga and people clapped
and then she was like she's like stay
the [__] out of our classes yoga's for
chicks you're [__] so then I got to
Stage I was like well give it up her she
was kind of a sexist pig huh and
everyone laugh and I was like I was like
you know I I was told that men that do
yoga are like in touch like that was you
know it's not just for women also I was
told that we shouldn't tell women they
should get nose jobs and just marry for
money turns out she's the piece of [__]
right and then I I think I called her
[__] a couple times but it was all like
part of the jokes whatever this chick
he's like I don't get it man she seemed
upset I called her [__] few times I
yeah but comedically it's like I didn't
say it to her face also like when you
get off stage people people say terrible
things about me once I get off stage cuz
they're going for the joke they're going
for the laugh if you want to play with
the big boys that's how Comedy Works
Russell Peters lit me up the other day
yeah just he goes he goes give it up for
Brennan uh I'm surprised usually when I
see him he's laying this way like get
knocked out fun I don't give a [__] yeah
just a dumb yeah if he just said it to
your face or something like that's
you're like [__] you no yeah but like on
stage for Laughs like that's how Comedy
Works so anyways she
leaves um blocks me on all the social
medias and then goes on this like
three-day like I was attacked on stage
by Jeff Dy and here's the thing you can
say the story you could say that I said
mean things about you that I said few
people like how dare you well here's the
thing she intentionally used the word
attacked because she wants she knows if
I if she says Jeff di made jokes about
me after I got upstair like grow up like
yeah you're comic but you intentionally
used the word attacked because you want
some you're trying to leverage some
power and it's just trash young people
do this all the time Jeff I verbally
assaulted oh no my ex she once said she
was like oh uh the guy before she wasn't
talking about me she was talking about
the guy she did before she goes he was
verbally abusive and you're like [__]
just say he was yelled at you yeah just
say just say you guys had argu yeah say
he was mean to you or he called you
names abusive is quite a term yeah you
you're you picture abuse you don't
picture like you know him going what the
[__] wrong with you but they have to
use that lingo in order for people to
jump on board right and Je roasted me
people like yeah comic happens yeah but
we're using all these words just wrong
it's it's very very annoying but it's
triggering words to trigger that fan
base so like but what I back to what you
were saying is like it's like my ex was
a narcissist really I just saw your post
you look kind of like a narcissist to me
is every it's always you in perfect
lighting with your side tit out like on
every post like I don't know you seem
pretty narcissistic as well and you
chose to be with you a a NFL tight end
who's like the hottest thing in the
world right now it seems like youai
probably were a perfect match it seems
like you guys were fit yeah watch out
Taylor watch out Taylor he's only after
one thing you know that all he cares
about his money and his social status
yeah like you you [__] [__]
people are so stupid people are so
stupid stupid what do you got chid
current events yeah all right uh first
one oh well we're going to bring it sad
right now real quick Matthew Perry that
was pretty shock I didn't even hear
about this till yesterday I didn't know
yeah till yesterday too but but
apparently I saw Matthew Perry jokes
before I even knew that he had passed
and I was like why is everyone dunking
on Matthew Perry yeah so apparently
drowning but apparently because my dad
told me he was like Hey drowned in a hot
tub and I'm like here jauz yeah but
isn't that how Whitney Houston died hers
was a bathtub and I think there's some
her daughter died her daughter died in a
bathtub too also drugs though but this
thing too I think his also it was a
heart condition I think he sank into the
water oh no so that's I think they still
need to do the a you know cuz I I was
reading a thing he so his parents put
him on some medication when he's young
it made him an addict so he's an addict
from a very an ad yeah but he was
working on it for a long time came on
the reunion of friendch just Hammer just
Blitz I was like this guy's awesome I
this guy's awesome K with it made me
like it
more um but yeah so he had uh not not
like any illegal drugs but he did have
like anti-depressants anti-anxiety drugs
which if you guys have ever taken it
it's I I've never taken it never like
like Xanax or anything no okay I have it
it makes you really sleepy fell asleep
I'm thinking he just took you know a
bunch of stuff and then he just probably
like drown said man I really like this
guy yeah I know it's a I'm not I don't
watch show friends I've seen like an
episode you know what I stopped watching
when we're going to pretend these five
broke young adults could afford that
giant Crib in New York people give me
[__] for watching pro wrestling they
answer that in the end the last episode
of Friends they were like well thank God
for rent control and they answered how
they can afford that apartment they
would KCK them out of you know rent
control works it's like a Jew that's
lived there from since the 60s it's not
like it's not like that that we've been
here for four years yeah what happened
we made this de four years ago yeah that
apartment would be I mean when I lived
in New York all my neighbors were like
these elderly Jewish women who were like
the sweetest women in the world who like
sexually harass me every day I'd come up
the stairs like there he is and they
[__] pinch me like I made you some
food you're going to come down and hang
out with me a little date you know it's
[__] they great ladies I loved them
all but they're also like they paid a
hundred a month and MTV was paying my
rent of that place was like
$144,000 a month it's not like they got
rank control for what how that's what
they said was Monica's grandma mother's
par oh okay that checks out say kept
living good at least they button it up
you know they could have said that early
in the episodes and maybe I've been a
fan uh do you guys know the YouTuber
Jack Doty who Jack doery uh i' have to
see his name I'm not I don't know many
YouTubers but I might recognize him so
what he do no so it's not not him his I
only watch Alex Jones on
YouTube so I'll just show you this
picture real quick you probably won't
recognize him unless you're like a
younger dude but that's Jack
dhy apparently a popular YouTuber his
security guard who was also the security
for the baby uh he knocked out this dude
at a Halloween party what's de why did
he knock him out you you'll see
everything here and this is like a very
famous girl classic Hooters outfit what
are they mad about apparently they were
going at Jack
Dory
[Applause]
oh that must that wait run it back I
want to see what he said that guy's big
gigantic I'm just saying just walk walk
dude [__] jeez that was [__] he is
too big to be hitting people like that
and it was that guy dead no he's not
dead you know how bad that would hurt is
he like 3 that guy's dead now him and
Matthew Perry Oh My All current events
are just guys that are dead she was like
on a high
note so uh so what happened so no so
apparently like uh that guy the popular
YouTuber dhy he he actually put that
film out that his his security guard
just you know knocked this guy out
apparently those people were like coming
at Jack dhy for some reason and but it
was not like there's no way that that
guy should have get punched that way you
know no he he's one of those liabilities
Jack like he was just off to the right
he was yeah which is weird
to isn't even close to Jacky and he
instigated this or he made it he
escalated the situation even more that's
the worst security can have the ones
that are looking for a problem yeah you
don't want that no it's like having
tekashi 69 as a buddy it's just like Jes
C me more problems hey man we at
McDonald's you have to pull a gun on the
lady that's my favorite thing about Mike
Tyson right so when you see Floyd money
right it's cuz people are always going
to try tough guys you know that probably
better than anybody people are going to
try and whatever and so like that's to
protect Floyd his the money teams to
protect Floyd Mike Tyson his Security is
to protect you from Mike yes because
Mike Mike will [__] anyone up anytime
maybe not my current times but in back
in the day he said try me dude you no
Tyson's like a lion at the zoo he looks
cool like yeah but it's in there say
some dumb [__] see what happens see what
happens yeah so this is the same
security guard apparently uh fans
figured out this is the same security
guard from the baby and this is
him guiding the baby out of a
concert why is that girl on him I mean
she's trying to I'm sure she trying to
flirt or
whatever I kind of like
this I mean look at this is a mess well
that one makes sense cuz that guy hit
the baby so someone did hit the baby
unfortunately the security guard hit a
girl this guy is bigger than I thought
he's gigantic so big did that whole
crowd is is at his like armpit height
either the whole crowd are small people
this is him they go hey
man his name's K if you want to come to
the baby show you better be under 5'8
[__] look at the size of this guy he's
gigantic yeah he's a fashion Nova model
too he's got yeah he's got like a lot of
followers he said no parents growing up
but I still came out decent so 638,000
this guy rules and he's followed by
Casey neist
who the [__] is that dude the biggest
YouTuber in the world case nist hey man
you're doing to YouTube this guy's so
big yeah yeah and he hit that skinny
white kid that was jacked up that was
not cool man he should not be doing that
if the if the kid hit him first I get it
but he didn't even if that you talking
about the soak and wet 13-year-old exact
if he hit him who gives a sh dude you're
so big yeah that was a dick move you're
also going to go to prison but yeah what
do you think is going to happen with
that lawsuit cuz especially since he's
associated with a YouTuber who's worth
millions that kid who was in that weird
outfit he's going to get millions just
to make this go away yeah that's uh
that's the world we live in and I was so
humiliated to get punched like that it
sucks but that was that cheap shot punch
knock the [__] I you jaws broke yeah oh
you think so oh the the just the he
turned into an accordion it wasn't like
a it wasn't like a it was like a thought
yeah but that was a cheap shot so
doesn't count it's he also like he was
like yeah what's up man
boom yeah was a cheap shot get out of
rough Halloween yeah that is tough and
also he fell back on some pavement I
like how the girls like how what are you
doing he's like who else wants some yeah
he goes I'll punch you too who else
wants like I I don't want that so wa
what all right here we go Blink 182 said
what the f is up with Denny's yeah so oh
no he performed in at Denny's yeah the
boys from blink wanted to recreate this
like famous little I a meme gift where
it's like a hardcore band playing like
in a d and literally saying what the
[__] is up Denny's so they went out to
Long Beach and they did a free impromptu
show pretty much announcing their new
tour the best thing ever happened to
Denny oh yeah for sure you been at
Denny's back on the map dude dude I'll
tell you right now there's nobody eating
at Denny's that has 75 Summers that
place isn't depressing as [__] dude it
is depressing this I don't know if it's
the lighting or what it is in there but
you go in you go what this is what it's
to the booths too you're like I hate am
man yeah I can't believe we're here I'd
rather be anywhere but at Denny's
anyways that's can't yeah can we hear it
a little I don't see I mean we okay I
can edit it out though but oh I
see well at least they still sound
good you can't hear anything yeah it
sounds like chaos you don't even have to
bleep but I would like more footage when
it wraps the waiter's like okay
so who heard the Flap Jack someone get
the Grand Slam meal here Grand Slam
what's up here just throw it in the
ground all right what's this one so
Magic Johnson just joined the
billionaires Club he's technically now
the fourth athlete to join this uh along
with Jordan LeBron Jordan and woods God
damn but Magic's done it how much of
that money did he get for pretending he
had AIDS oh my
God remember when he said hi everybody I
have HIV will like fine remember will
him play basetball yeah they're like
well I don't want to sweat on yeah
they're like V start dude it was so
homophobic back then cuz the players
like nah man we don't feel comfortable
down there in the post with the guy with
a what if he looks at us yeah what if he
sneezes yeah and Jerry Wes was like good
point yeah good point these are all
valid arguments we get it we're making
the guy retire yeah that's exactly what
they did they shows if you have enough
money you can beat AIDS though man dude
no I think that it's not a money thing I
think they they needed a face of like
that and they just gave him a ton of
money said can you just pretend you have
this let's let's play in a world where
you you actually did have have HIV also
there's only a few ways a straight man
gets a AIDS I know why did nobody talk
about that so is he a drug addict I
don't think so did he have some butt sex
maybe with a dude especially back then
very likely figure it out I heard that
his kids have butt sex with men only one
though for for sure yeah his his one son
EPO genetics his one son's magical man
yeah dude that those photos he's also 69
even you could be the nicest guy in the
world you look at some of those photos
and you just you go Jeff don't
laugh you know like when you see like
Dwayne Wade's kid or you see Magic's kid
you look at those photos and you're like
just be a good person it's not funny oh
dude you see that photo there's no way
not to laugh I do red carpet that was
the comedy relief and Magic son walked
in I was like I'm just going to I don't
want canell it's funny to me also out of
all the Suns the only one who has all
the sugar in the tank has the height
yeah oh yeah it's true yeah the other
ones are like small and then you know
like you don't want to pick up
basketball he's like nah man it's such a
funny world we live in like currently
and everyone's just everyone is such a
[__] coward that they don't want to
say
anything we just can't be honest yeah
I'd like to go back how magic got the
age the HIV wait what's that uh photo
six over on the top with his son who's
jacked in the back
yeah that's magic and that's his other
son yeah know that's his son how many
kids does he got boy magic is thick dude
yeah Magic's a beast dude I love Magic
Johnson oh dude he's more like LeBron
than than LeBron is a Jordan he's the
only reason Jabar is nice yeah so one of
his sons is a football player no that's
Andre Johnson I looked at the sons Magic
Johnson Sons it says Andre Johnson and
egyp Johnson no well no different Andre
yeah Andre is one of the greatest all
time that's the Google's fault and he's
from Miami yeah we're not mad at you
yeah yeah whatever what does EJ Johnson
do for
a a life like what what is the let's
take a look is on the Rich Kids of
Beverly Hills I don't never seen
that a television personality a
socialite and a fashion
commentator so
nothing yeah
what does the W9
say yeah where you make your money Dad
yeah I think so well also dad's a
billionaire I know that's the funny
thing about our life too is or like the
world we live in my sisters used to
always be like like I'm going to be
famous I'm like for what and they like
just I just am like that's not how Fame
works but it is now you can't just do
nothing but it is now I know now now
everyone thinks they should be famous
just cuz they're hot well when I was a
kid my dad like if you stay and play
video games you're be a loser never make
any money my son like Dad I'm just going
to play video games like all right well
share with Dad could make a bill in you
know start a twitch kid what do you got
chin god dog yeah that's EJ dude his dad
invested in Starbucks and movie Magic
movie theaters movie theaters are kind
of down right now but back in the day he
made all his money with uh movie and
Starbucks he put Starbucks in like hoods
um yeah I you wait you don't like movie
theaters you think they're done oh I
love them I'm just saying lately
I've been going about once a week I'm
back into it man I like it it feels like
a whole thing feels like this like whole
event I dig it you see the new Leon
Leonardo DiCaprio movie n it looks
boring is it good I didn't see it HS
three and half you like smart stuff I'm
like a pretty simple guy I like scary
movies no I like scary but like jet ski
on fire some hot chick I like that kind
of stuff robot no not that but like I
don't know I just I like a action like
Meg you seen this thing yeah my kid
kiddos love it I like giant shark you
got I'm in sharks I'm in what's the guy
Jason Statham been he's been in 400
movies he's got five lines total he
jumps on the shark he he's awesome yeah
I love it I'm going to blow this shark
up you're like that's my guy dude yeah
I'll watch it what's this Jin uh Georgie
oh dude this is great have you seen new
playing basketball little Chinese kid oh
boy yeah a ton of fans sent this in he
trucks him he trucks himself too Let me
refresh he trucked this kid trying to
like cross him over oh can't wait for
the comment
oh look he and he can't get the ball on
his finger like he keeps trying yeah oh
look behind the back what's up kid
what's up
kid he grabs me
like I just [__] with you
man oh he must be
mortified he's all right we just B and
he lands on his legs the kid's
legs dude he keeps trying to handle the
ball like he's all good at it he does
cross him up at first boom when we got
to start a campaign to stop making these
po stop pretending politicians are cool
it started with Obama where like because
he's a black guy would they would like
interview him like on ESP and like oh
tell us about your bracket dude I want
you at a desk stacks of papers pulling
your hair out going how are we going to
get out of this [__] Iraq I don't
want to hear your bracket I don't care I
don't want to hear you on Jimmy Kimmel
yes what are you throwing out a first pi
the [__] they're not cool get like he's
trying to put it behind his back like
look I'm going to dunk on a Chinese kid
stop it you're not cool you're not
interesting do boring politics [__] hey
guys I'm y me Y what is he doing out
there why are we talking to him don't
get why we're and he's trying not to be
he's like we got a real Jeremy Lynn over
here hey dude it's the only Asian player
you know it's
unreal all right what's this one all
right is it your not okay I'll do it
well you guys were talking about
SeaWorld earlier um literally segue yeah
well this Australian server literally
got like manhandled by a killer whale
while surfing and I don't know why
people go into the ocean when you say
manhandled I think he says humpback are
you trying to be the YouTube like help
YouTube algorithm by saying unlived no
manhandled manhandled into heaven I mean
just watch the clip all right let's
watch the clip so it is she's already
mad at me oh look at this did
he oh so the whale just jumped and then
hit him I tell me if I'm crazy or if you
guys agree I don't think that's a
coincidence no he's probably the thing
he probably killed his brothers and [__]
so he's like [__] humans well I think
that like these animals keep jumping up
on boats yeah there was like the orca
attacks yeah they're like not trying to
hurt anybody but they're like eating
eating at the boat or like getting up on
like things have been knock these seals
have been knocking surf boarders over it
seems like a thing patter dolphins have
fun dolphins have fun likeing Surfers
over yeah it's happened so I think it's
a thing I don't think that's an accident
like I don't think Super they're also
living in the ocean bored as [__] yeah
dude and they're like dude knock that
piece of [__] over they're down there
like us and they you want to go to the
surface and [__] with these dorks on the
board let's go man he's like what are we
going to do they just like kids getting
in trouble yeah they don't have jobs to
se let's go upstairs and let's go to the
top of the surface and [__] with these
surface what's that chin so Brian our
boy Brian count sent us this video and I
thought it was kind of weird right it
was like in peace it was like random
it's like weird but he sent us this
video and then he made sure to to make
us look at the the comments so I'll show
you the video first this Brian be like
make sure you show this video for me I
don't that's what this is let so that's
her husband this girl this is Salmon Run
hurry she look she's doing nothing hurry
so she wants to save the salmon he's
going to die in front of us by the tail
I you can do it this guy so he can't do
it just grab it so she grabs a little
plastic bag wait it's not dead and they
put him in the plastic bag no and by the
way they're messing with nature here oh
my I know these people have no business
being I'm so annoyed he just catching
its breath great job so the main thing
was the guy the husband was just
couldn't so yeah he couldn't even grab a
fish you could buy a stupid hat but it
doesn't mean you'd be good in
nature wait Ken sent us this yes so even
Johnny John how telling make the podcast
come to Screech and halt from Dallas no
but read the comments I'm telling you
when I I read the comments it was so
funny this can't be real you both need
to start seeing other
men that's a great dude there's so many
good ones here uh I ref to believe this
man isn't actually gay he has to be
there's no way and that got 7,000 likes
soone said why didn't you just put the
fish in his purse
and it's about the comments this makes
me embarrassed to own a
Subaru the super com is so funny this
dude's daughter's the man of the
house
proof that buying a brand new paduchi
from REI doesn't automatically make you
an Outdoorsman that's what I was saying
you bought the dumb hat and now act like
a [__] Outdoorsman some but a flat
tire must be detrimental for
your I mean there this video dropped my
tea levels 300 points your wife's
boyfriend would have grabbed that fish
no
problem Oh my good God there's a lot of
likes things there so many amazing
comments bro it's a fish holy crap we
need more natural predators that fish is
more firmer than his
Eng dude they're so good yeah but
there's tons anyways we can't go through
all them it dude this is awesome also
like it is pretty problematic that he
couldn't just grab a [__] fish oh
dude when I looked at I was like oh my
god dude we're not talking about like
tuna where you got that's the whole
waste or something or a catfish would
have like you know I would assume he's
in electric car catfish can even bite
you it don't hurt yeah that guy probably
that guy probably drives a Tesla that's
that's that cult Vibe oh you have a
Tesla now right that's a bummer oh you
can't talk bummer it it's funny actually
was funny I was on a show and this guy
the other day um before me he was like
he was like I'm not one of these little
[__] guys I'm trying to think what
he started with he was saying oh these
[__] straight white males who drive
Teslas and have a golden doodle right
and then I just literally nudge the guy
go put me on next yeah that's exactly
I'm about to [__] this show up I'm a I'm
very straight very white very male and I
have a Tesla and a [__] golden doodle
so let's go but you have a Tesla golden
doodle but then you also have like an
got giant military Jeeps and you're the
you're the outlier with Tesla I also I'm
the only Tesla with like military wheels
and like a lift and tires you're
different you're different you get a you
get a pass I've affected the range of my
Tesla by half by putting giant military
tires and wheels on it looks cool is
that yeah it does look badass is that it
CH that's it unless she has one another
one Jeffrey where you at dude you you on
tour uh I am but I'm not sure where I'm
at so let's look at my calendar here I
go to Canada soon at Ontario uh no
Ontario is California is all right
November 8th Ontario California going to
The Improv then I'm in Calgary Alberta
at the laugh shop November 9th to the
11th Calgary great and then San Jose for
The Improv um November 16th so check me
out or go to jeff.com get your tickets
please oh then you're going to Comedy
Works Greenwood Village my that's for
New Year's New Year's Eve weekend Oh
dope yeah tell them yeah I have some
people there for sure I'm in Niagara
Falls New York this Friday Saturday both
shows almost sold out that's one show
Friday one show Saturday with Brett
Forte the great Brett Forte right
outside Buffalo I hear I'm Chicago
December 8th and 9th two shows Friday
two shows Saturday and the keep on
trucking tour continues in January uh
one night in Nashville January 25th then
two nights in Austin Texas January 26
27th all right kids Jeff love you buddy
love you man thanks for having me bro we
love you Callen